Disney's animated Lion King will always hold
a special place in people's hearts.
But the 2019 version takes the opportunity
to correct some of the crazy plot holes, goofs,
and mistakes fans have spotted over the years
in the original.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm explaining how The Lion King
remake fixes many of those issues from the
90s classic.
Some spoilers ahead, so take care if you haven't
seen it yet.
Don't forget my Lion King giveaway is still
running, so be sure to subscribe and leave
a comment about the movie for your chance
to win.
The animated Lion King's opening scene and
'Circle of Life' song are iconic moments that
the remake mostly reproduces shot-for-shot,
however, it also fixes a few crucial errors
from the 1994 movie.
Just before Simba's presentation, Rafiki anoints
him, breaking open a fruit to release a red
liquid which he paints on the young cub's
forehead, before dusting his face to dry the
mark.
The fruit that Rafiki brings with him appears
to come from the ancient baobab tree that
he lives in, and the problem with the original
scene is that a baobab fruit doesn't contain
a red liquid and is actually dry inside with
white pulp and large seeds.
In the new movie, the filmmakers have fixed
this by having Rafiki use some red roots which
release a red dust when he breaks them.
It's also this red powder that makes little
Simba sneeze rather than Rafiki dousing the
poor little cub in a handful of dust as he
did in the animation.
The 2019 movie also changes the hand that
Rafiki uses to anoint Simba from his left
hand to his right.
This is consistent with the fact that Rafiki
is right-handed when he's fighting the hyenas
with his stick later in both movies.
Rafiki himself was misrepresented in the original
movie as, although he's modelled after a mandrill,
in the film and the screenplay he's referred
to as a baboon.
Some of the Disney animators even thought
of him as a "mutated" monkey and gave him
physical features such as a long tail which
is incorrect for a mandrill.
"It means you are a baboon, and I'm not."
"I think you're a little confused."
"Wrong!"
That baboon reference has been eliminated
from the new movie and Rafiki's design has
also been corrected, by replacing the long
tail he had in the animation with a short
stub that's biologically accurate for his
species.
Another mistake corrected in the new Lion
King is the colour of Simba's eyes.
In reality, new-born lion cubs start life
with blue-grey eyes.
Then after two or three months, a cub's eyes
turn an orangey-brown colour.
The remake reflects this as you can see young
Simba has dark-bluish eyes at the time of
his presentation.
And once he's grown up a little, they're a
darker yellowy-orange colour.
In the animation, as a new-born cub Simba
simply has dark eyes and when he's older his
eyes are a browny colour.
And to make us connect with the characters
and their feelings even more, the original
animators gave the lions eyes that were very
like humans, so they have a pupil, an iris
and a white of their eyes which is sometimes
coloured yellow.
Even though real-life lions don't have whites
in their eyes.
Scar's bright green eyes have also been changed
for a better sense of realism in the reboot.
The original movie was also guilty of featuring
numerous wild animals that aren't native to
the film's African setting.
For example, when Simba sings "I Just Can't
Wait To Be King", various animals construct
a crazy tower and on the very top are a group
of giant anteaters.
Giant anteaters are only native to Central
and South America and so wouldn't be seen
in the wild in Africa.
So, this time around, the filmmakers have
made sure there's no giant anteaters in the
movie.
Other non-African animals that were also scrubbed
from the latest film include the tail-hanging
monkeys that also make an appearance during
"I Just Can't Wait to be King".
And the gopher that pops up during Zazu's
"morning report" also hit the cutting room
floor in the remake for the same reason.
"Zazu."
"Yes?!"
"Sir, news from the underground."
One mistake which has been left in the new
version is the inclusion of leaf-cutter ants.
These appear in the opening sequence in both
movies even though they're only native to
the Americas.
I think they kept these misplaced ants in
the film for two reasons.
First of all, the filmmakers wanted to keep
the Circle of Life sequence more or less shot-for-shot.
And secondly, the ants play a special part
later in Rafiki discovering that Simba is
still alive.
The animated movie often emphasises how dim-witted
the hyenas are:
"Zazu, you told me they're nothing but slobbering,
mangy, stupid poachers."
"lx-nay on the upid-stay."
"Who are you callin' upid-stay?"
But this doesn't reflect the fact that in
real-life hyenas are intelligent, skilled,
and dangerous predators.
Which is why Shenzi, who's voiced by Black
Panther's Florence Kasumba, is a lot more
menacing in the new version.
"You're no match for us Sarabi!
You will die with your king Nala!"
And although the hyenas are still antagonists
in the remake, the Nazi goose-stepping scene
has been cut to fit the new film's more realistic
and grounded approach.
Hard-core Lion King fans may have noticed
a small change in the new movie when Simba
and Nala are reunited.
"Where have you been?!"
In the original film, as they rub their heads
together you can also hear them purring, much
like a pet cat does.
However, in the remake Simba and Nala's purring
has been removed, likely because animal experts
believe lions either don't purr at all or
the noises they make are technically different
to the purr of a domestic cat.
Following Simba and Nala's reunion is "Can
You Feel The Love Tonight?" which the original
filmmakers described as "perhaps the most
steamy love scene in any Disney film."
During the song, Nala gives Simba what the
filmmakers have called a "Come Hither" look.
In the new film that moment is replaced with
Nala giving Simba an affectionate lick, which
fits with the remake's much more realistic
depiction of animal behaviour.
In the 1994 movie, Rafiki discovers that Simba
is still alive after the lion flops down on
some plants and the earth and leaves which
scatter are magically carried by the wind
all the way to the wise monkey's tree where
he reads the leaves in an empty tortoise shell.
The new movie has a quite ingenious and perhaps
more feasible method for Rafiki to discover
the truth about Simba.
This time a tuft of Simba's fur falls off
and goes on a complex journey, floating on
the wind, then a river before being eaten
with some leaves by a giraffe and ending up
in a ball of dung that a beetle rolls along.
That ball falls down a hill and breaks apart
releasing the tuft of hair, which a leaf-cutter
ant then collects and marches up the Tree
of Life where Rafiki spots it and recognises
it as Simba's fur.
It's a nice little updated sequence which
also fits with the film's "circle of life"
theme.
In the first film, there's a curious goof
in the scene where Simba and Nala visit the
elephant graveyard.
"I wonder if its brains are still in there."
"There's only one way to know.
Come on, let's go check it out."
The young lion cubs are ambushed by the hyenas
who emerge from the skull of a dead elephant.
However, fans have commented that when you
look more closely at the proportions of the
skull, it's grotesquely large and far too
big when compared to real-life elephant skulls.
Which is why the 2019 movie skips over the
hyenas coming out of the skulls, and instead
they meet Simba and Nala inside a cave.
Another problem fixed from the animated Circle
of Life sequence is Rafiki's seemingly impossible
ascent to Pride Rock from the front.
If you look at the shape of Pride Rock and
how it juts out, it would be extremely difficult
for Rafiki to climb up beneath it and very
silly too given he could access the rock via
a much easier route instead.
The new movie fixes with this by showing Rafiki
walking on to the top via a much more gently-sloping
rock face.
As you can see, the new Lion King tends to
tone down some of the animation's more exaggerated,
cartoony moments to better fit the photo-realism
of the new CG version.
"What is it?"
"That is not a lion, it's a furry bird!"
"Looks like a lion."
"Th.. is not a lion.
Let me get a closer look."
So, the remake changes this moment where Timon
lifts Simba's paw up all the way above his
head in an incredible feat of strength for
a tiny little meerkat.
Instead, the new movie, has Timon identifying
Simba as a lion by looking at his teeth.
"It's a lion!
Run for your life Pumbaa!"
"Hey Timon, wait, wait, wait, Timon!
Wait, it's a little lion!"
"It gets bigger!"
Another scene made more realistic this time
around is when Nala chases Pumbaa.
In the original movie, the warthog rather
foolishly tries to escape her by squeezing
through a gap under a tree root that's too
small for him.
"How bleak is that?"
Which is why it doesn't happen like that in
the new story, and instead Pumbaa is cornered
by Nala when he slips and falls trying to
run up a moss-covered rock.
Another small but important change, which
die-hard Lion King fans may have noticed,
is that after Scar is defeated and Simba walks
out on to Pride Rock, in the remake Zazu says
"your majesty".
It's a nice fix to the 1994 ending where Zazu
says these words to Simba but the actual audio
ended up cut from the final film.
If you watch the animated scene closely, you'll
see Zazu mouth the words as Simba walks past,
but the dialogue can't be heard.
That mistake was introduced because the filmmakers
thought a moment of silence would add more
gravitas to the scene.
However, they didn't redo the animation to
stop Zazu's mouth moving.
Speaking of adding things to the film, the
new movie also adds some new meta moments
and Disney easter eggs in the Timon and Pumbaa
scenes, and I talk all about that in my Lion
King comparison video.
Tap the screen to watch that or click the
link in the video description.
Now, did you spot any new plot holes or mistakes
in The Lion King remake?
Let me know in the comments below and subscribe
to enter the giveaway!
Congratulations to the winner of my Spider-Man
giveaway.
Contact me via email from my "About" page
so I can send you your prize!
Tap left for my next Lion King video or tap
right for another Disney video or something
else you're sure to like.
And if you enjoyed this, a like and a share
are always hugely appreciated.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!